[Applause]
[Music]
hey there visual politic Community have
you ever noticed that if we take a look
at the map of the world and analyze it
in detail you'll realize there are some
very unusual borders for example the one
between Spain and Morocco through the
cities of sauta and Mala is one that
attracts a lot of attention the ones
separating Israel from Gaza and the West
Bank are also some of the most most
strange what can I say but let me ask
you a question do you know of any island
with a strange border do you know of a
case of an island split in half and
where the two halves how should we put
it politely can't stand each other very
well well yes such islands and borders
do exist many of you may be thinking of
the borders between brune and Indonesia
or papano guini and Tiny East teamour or
maybe you're thinking about Cyprus or
irand however this time we are not
heading to Southeast Asia nor will we
stay in Europe today we will find our
protagonists in the middle of the
Caribbean Sea because it turns out there
is another island in the Caribbean that
is also home to two countries can you
tell me which one it is three 2 1 Bingo
indeed we are talking about the island
of
[Music]
Hispanola and is precisely here where we
find the Dominican Republic and the
Republic of Haiti two very different
countries both in terms of culture and
economic and social development if you
remember the video we made on visual
politic about Haiti you will know
perfectly well that this island could be
the perfect board for the perfect set
for Grand Design's Island Edition we're
talking about two countries that also
share a murky history of old Border
fights something that seemed to have
been overcome yet in the last 2 years
border tensions have resurfaced the rise
of Haitian gangs has toughened the
Dominican Republic's border and
immigration policy of course besides the
gangs there is another powerful reason
that has intensified the tension we are
talking once again about natural
resources especially in this case a very
particular one war visual politics
viewers how did this atypical and
controversial border come to be
established what is the Dominican
Republic doing to try and curb the rise
of Haitian gangs why do we say that the
two Spanish-speaking countries are at
loggerheads over water today we're going
to answer these questions but first we
have to start the story at the
[Music]
beginning one below after
another if there's one thing that can
unite both the Dominican Republic and
the Haitian Nation it's their past as
colonies of two European Empires the
Spanish and the French specifically
Haiti achieved independence from France
in 1804 and the Dominican Republic did
the same from Spain in 1821 from then on
far from extending a hand A Century Of
Constant struggles between the two
countries began above all for one reason
the continuous Haitian Invasion attempts
it seems that having a new country to
build was not enough for
them only one year after gaining its
independence the Dominican Republic was
invaded by the Haitian leader Jean
Pierre Boer who would dominate all of
Hispanola from 1822 to 1844 Boer soon
earned the hatred of Dominicans with
measures such as the expulsion of
teachers from the country the
expropriation of land from the church
and the obligation to repay part of the
debt that Haiti had contracted with
France years before and so in 1844 the
Dominican Republic led by juam Pablo du
and Pedro Santana among others managed
to game Independence again only this
time from neighboring Haiti nevertheless
Haiti's attacks did not cease for
example in 1855 the Haitian Emperor
Forin the sent 30,000 soldiers to the
Dominican Republic with the intention of
conquering it again but this time he was
unsuccessful since then Haiti has never
again launched large scale attacks to
take the Dominican Republic but with the
failure of all negotiations and
mediations the french-speaking nation
did continue to make small incursions
into Dominican
territory but then 1929 came and that
brought with it finally a peace treaty
recognizing the 1856 borders of the two
countries the Dominican Republic then
had to give up a border region that had
been occupied by Haiti after 1856 but
other than that the agreement was well
received by the governments of both
countries but not surprisingly the story
did not end
[Music]
there the agreement was on the verge of
being broken by a terrible and
Despicable event The Parsley Massacre on
the daabon in 1937 you see in 193 this
man you see on the screen came to power
in the Dominican Republic Raphael
Leonidas Tru he was a lieutenant colonel
and Chief of Staff when he successfully
carried out the coup that put him in
power under truo the policy towards
Haitians was hardened to trust me
completely terrifying levels historical
resentment for the continual Haitian
invasions and above all an openly racist
ideology LED tro to order the ethnic
cleansing of Haitians in the Dominican
Republic yep that's what I said between
the 2nd and the 8th of October 19 1937
the Dominican military using criminals
and convicts armed with machetes and
bayonets killed between 9,000 and 20,000
Haitians both on Dominican soil and On
the Border itself it was a true and
atrocious Massacre however despite this
the agreement remained in place and in
the end both the dictator tro and the
Haitian Eli leco put a definitive end to
the Border disputes in 1942 the Border
was then free of fighting and since then
both Haitians and Dominicans have been
able to pass from one side to the other
with relative flexibility even so as I
was telling you before since 2021 the
Border has become redh hot again and all
because of a new threat capable of
disrupting everything haian gangs listen
up the profound Haitian
chaos I think we all know that Latin
America is experiencing a wave of
violence that is making countries that
seemed reasonably safe just 5 years ago
such as Ecuador Chile and Costa Rica to
now register a large in crime rates
nevertheless despite the worrisome
situation in these countries nothing
compares to what is happening in Haiti
we already told you here on visual
politic how the phenomenon of gangs and
militias in Haiti is not exactly
something new in fact we can trace them
back to the 1950s with the tonon maku
during the devalier dictatorship
typically these gangs were in the
service of politicians and businessmen
who were seeking both protection and
greater power however in 20121 we were
faced with news that would change the
Haitian landscape dramatically haian
president hovel Mo assassinated at his
home by unidentified gunmen indeed in
July 2021 mercenaries mostly Colombians
assassinated the then president jovano
Moise following that event this man you
see on screen Ariel enry took over the
presidency of the country on a temporary
basis but despite this The Gangs noted
that mace's assassination had left a
tremendous power vacuum a vacuum which
not surprisingly they were quick to fill
the country now has nearly 200 gangs 100
of which are present in the Haitian
Capital port or Prince which which has
become a veritable Jungle of predatory
gangs in fact for many the capital has
already fallen completely into the hands
of these
gangs gangs such as the moo 400
considered the most extensive in the
country or the G9 the most powerful
coition of gangs in all of Haiti already
control the coast of Porter Prince which
is precisely where the major port
terminals for the country's Commerce are
located as you can imagine this gives
them enormous power but to give you an
idea of just how much power they have
accumulated you should know that the G9
even took over the veru terminal which
is the main oil terminal in the country
Haiti was then left without Fuel and the
Haitian National Police had to redouble
its efforts to gain back access Visual
politics viewers the situation of
violence in the Caribbean nation has
reached such a level that even the
interim president Ariel HRI has called
for an international military
intervention in the country crazy but
okay sure I'm certain many of you are
wondering but Jake how does this affect
the Dominican Republic well you see the
truth is that the Dominican Republic
plays a crucial role here for one simple
reason it's one of the main hubs of drug
and arms trafficking from which Haitian
gangs
profit according to the United Nations
office on drugs and crime the Dominican
Republic is one of the main access
points for weapons arriving from Florida
and destined for Haitian gangs in fact
to give you an idea in the first 6
months of 2022 and in the port of hyena
alone in Santo Domingo West 112,000
units of weapons and ammunition from the
United states were confiscated and not
only that the Dominican Republic also
plays a key role in drug trafficking a
fundamental business for Haitian gangs
in other words the Dominican Republic
has become a kind of crime market for
Haitian gangs both an entry and exit
point of that market because we're
talking about an island that has become
a very important distribution point for
the shipment of Narcotics to both
Western Europe and the United
States this chaotic situation in Haiti
has led the Dominican Republic to
tighten measures for every entry into
the the country from the other side of
the island fearing that Haitian gangs
could extend their activity into the
Dominican Republic Louise abinader the
president of the country has not
hesitated in carrying out a massive
deportation campaign a campaign that has
made no distinction by age or gender so
for example in 2022 it came to deport
171,000 people 102% more than in 2021
and take note because in 2023 it's
expected that the number of deportations
could reach 250,00 for the time being
however and despite everything the
borders had remained relatively open
especially to facilitate trade between
the two countries nevertheless recent
events are changing this reality
tensions On the Border have returned
after Decades of relative stability and
trust me abada is proving that he's not
taking the situation lying down check it
out the Dominican
Trump remember the world worldwide
uproar When Donald Trump said he wanted
to build a wall between the US and
Mexico it was an idea that marked his
2016 campaign and about which the
international media talked nonstop well
do you know who has also announced the
construction of a wall and is fulfilling
his promise indeed Luise abin himself
controversial wall to separate
prosperous Dominican Republic and
impoverished Haiti once completed the
Border fence an impressive 4 M High
concrete and steel construction will
span some 164 km and divide the
Dominican Republic from neighboring
Haiti president abinader has argued that
one of his main objectives for this war
is to keep potential Haitian gang
members and criminals out of the
Dominican Republic yet another reason is
to better control migratory flows Haiti
is a place of economic and social chaos
mered in deep levels of violence so as
you can imagine in the last 2 years
hundreds of thousands of Haitians have
flooded into the Dominican Republic
which has created a severe strain on
hospital care and not only that with all
this new labor available Dominican wages
have also Fallen keep in mind that
Haitians offer their labor at a lower
price that explains why a large part of
the Dominican population has welcomed
this measure with open arms but
naturally there is no shortage of
critics many say that the war will be
useless and that the corruption of the
Dominican border soldiers will allow
Haitians to pass in exchange for bribes
others fear that the war will hinder the
entry of Haitian workers who are crucial
to the Dominican economy consider for
example that 80% of the labor force in
the Dominican Republic's agricultural
sector is Haitian however this does not
have to be too concerning after all it
doesn't mean that Haitians will not be
able to enter their neighboring country
only that there will be a stricter
control of access in other words it
won't necessarily affect Haitian
workers even so in September of this
year we came across another piece of
news that came as a real shock and made
it very clear that the Border situation
between the two countries was once again
heating up Dominican Republic announces
it will close its border with Haiti over
water dispute the measure comes amidst a
conflict over access to a river shared
by both countries indeed Vig politic
Community Louise abinader ordered to
close the border with Haiti because of a
dispute over waterer from the massacre
River also known as the daabon river you
see the thing is in 2018 Haiti started
to build an irrigation system using the
Rivers's water for crops growing in the
Mari baru plane construction was
suspended when yanel Moes was
assassinated in 2021 but farmers in the
area decided to resume construction
themselves in August of this year after
all construction was already 60%
complete well the fact is that when the
Haitian Farmers resumed construction
abinader was Furious the Dominican
president demanded that construction be
stopped saying it would affect more than
14,000 hectares of Dominican farmland
and the saladia lagoon one of the
country's few wetlands in the end the
president decided to suspend the
issuance of visas to Haitians and
finally to completely close the border
with Haiti faced with this serious
situation which goes beyond the limits
of the neighboring country directly
affecting our interests and legitimate
rights we have stood the need to give a
forceful response in legitimate defense
against uncontrollable groups that do
not obey the Haitian constitutional
order however the Border closure has not
only affected Haitians but also the
thousands of Dominicans who depend on
trade with Haiti for example in the
daabon a Dominican border town the
citizens liveed largely from this trade
and when the borders were closed the
economic Devastation was soon felt it
should be noted that according to the
mayor of the Town Santiago riveron every
week the equivalent of $4 million is
traded in the buying National Market of
daabon and as in this municipality the
same happens at other border crossings
such as elas Pena or pedales that is why
in the middle of October 2023 the
Dominican government was forced to
partially reopen some border enclaves to
reactivate trade with the neighboring
country it is true there is still a
strict control on the access of Haitians
but this is already one step closer to a
return to
normality meanwhile Haiti's farmers and
government have not given in they defend
their right to exploit their own natural
resources and well they're right after
all the canal they're building has its
origins in the 2 and a half km of river
on Haitian soil what's more it's logical
that they would seek the construction of
this canal with food insecurity
affecting at least five of its 11 and a
half million citizens it's estimated
that the canal would increase rice
cultivation in such a way as to ensure
food for at least 4 million Haitians
this position is also shared by the
former president and candidate of the
Dominican opposition for the May 2024
elections Leonel Fernandez he relied on
a study by the National Institute of
water resources of the Dominican
Republic to support the Haitian project
and called the Dominican government's
position exaggerated and hypocritical
especially considering that the
Dominican Republic has 11 canals similar
to the one Haiti is building so you see
the border between Haiti and the
Dominican Republic is once again under
enormous tension the increase in
criminality in Haiti due to gangs and
the conflict over the water of the
massacre River has brought border
tension back in into the spotlight
president abinader has acted forcefully
building a wall lightning entry policies
for Haitians and even partially closing
the borders many have supported him
others have branded him an exaggerator
an opportunist and a populist who knows
that such measures are very popular with
an electoral that will be called to vote
in May 2024 but what do you think do you
think these measures are fair or
exaggerated and do you think they will
be able to reach an agreement to reopen
the borders you can leave me your answer
in the comments as always don't forget
that here on visual politic we release
new videos every week so subscribe to
this Channel and hit that little bell so
you don't miss any of our updates if you
like this video like it and see you in
the next one all the best and see you
[Music]
soon